last night's episode of survivor 42 was
one of the most shocking to date and
this is after 41 seasons so that is
saying something it's so complicated
yeah not only did we witness a historic
tribal council which we'll get into a
minute but we also saw a survivor first
in the immunity challenge take a look
drag guys ladders in
come in
drag it right up here and place it here
and wait
perfect right there is good
drop it
all right here's what we're gonna do
due to no
lack of effort on your part
this is not getting any easier we're
gonna retrieve your keys and give them
to you and we'll continue the challenge
from here sound fair oh yeah
never done this in the history of
survivor let's get the keys
wow all right we are joined by our
special survivor correspondent in season
41 winner erica kasoopenin hello erica
hi roz hi sangeeta it's so good to be
back on my own little island to talk all
things survivor and i am so ready all
right erica holy smokes that challenge
is the first time in survivor history
that jeff stalled the challenge because
of the swells in the water do you think
it was the right call i mean i've run a
lot of challenges i know sangeeta you've
run a challenge before too and
challenges are hard and when you're
hungry and when the water is acting up
like that it's frankly dangerous and i
think it was absolutely the right call
yeah now after the challenge the teku
tribe was told to select two players to
go on a journey and they ended up
choosing omar and chanel now erica i
need to get your thoughts on this whole
journey thing because where omar and
chanel had to decide to either risk
their vote or protect their vote we
obviously saw what happened
with chanel risking her vote despite
communicating to omar that she would do
the opposite that meant that both chanel
and mike wouldn't be able to vote during
tribal council
crazy i know and i think these decisions
are so complicated because it's not just
do i want this advantage you have to
think about what is the other person
thinking and more importantly what does
the other person think that i'm thinking
and i think that omar when he looked at
the situation thought i'm safe tonight
i've already voted i know where my
loyalties lie in my tribe whereas chanel
she was at risk that night she's never
voted and she knew that mike her ally
would not be able to vote too so i think
that chanel took a bigger risk i don't
know if it was the right risk to take
this time around geez okay so let's talk
tribal because that was a wild ride
despite everyone thinking they were a
united front things got real for vati uh
tribe after uh chanel learned her fate
leaving only four tribe members to vote
this is nuts yeah the results a two-two
tie between jenny and lydia and during
the re-vote only hai and daniel's voted
votes counted leaving jeff to reveal
that there was another tie
yes and that's where hai's mind was
absolutely blown he had no idea that
both chanel and mike didn't vote and
then jeff told them that if they didn't
come to a unanimous decision then jenny
and lydia will then be safe and the
other four will have to draw rocks
all right my mind is so blown right now
i don't know unfortunately for mike and
chanel
jeff made them reveal that they lost
their votes and said that although they
can try and influence the decision it
was up to hai and daniel to decide who
would go oh boy
and this is where i think daniel got
himself into a bit of trouble i had a
lot of people on twitter ask me if they
thought if i thought that daniel kind of
ended his game so early and if he has a
chance to win still and i think that
daniel made a lot of missteps that night
he
outed who his allies were but then he
tried to throw his ally chanel under the
bus and then he switched sides during
the potential rock draw and as much as i
think i know from personal experience
what happens in the pre-merge on
survivor it's cool but the game is won
in the post merge so do i think daniel
still has a shot to win
yeah
i think he just has dug a deep hole
called him a snake he he and i saw the
conversation between chanel
i know oh i don't know i don't know how
this is all gonna go yet there's a lot
of bickering and talking over each other
but hai made it clear that he wasn't
changing his vote and that he was
willing to draw rocks that's insane and
after hai and lydia promised not to hold
his vote against him daniel's fear of
drawing rocks caused him to give jenny
the boot
yes and i'm i have watched survivor for
more than 20 years i have one survivor
and i think this whole situation is so
complicated i think that going to rocks
for a boat while it's stunning tv and
crazy to watch i think it's a sign that
something has gone wrong in the gameplay
so somebody has either not properly
convinced someone that they should be
confident i think that somebody has
maybe um overestimated how well they're
doing socially and then we kind of end
up with this mess it's a mess it's a
mess
i don't even know this is like and this
is did you get all that this is early in
the season